watch that entire video but this video
is Palestinians in their movement for
[Music]
[Applause]
liberation
of the left there was a lot of
disagreement different writers how I
mean this is horrible
for it's horrible for so many people
artists among them the the basic uh
tenant of of making art right you can
have a voice um if you if you don't have
that then what do you
[Music]
have
it's difficult um for the law to address
these kinds of firings because there
really are two competing interests here
um companies do have an associational
right to choose who they have in their
company and if they want to have
everybody with one political point of
view you know theoretically that's their
right they're not going to be a very
successful company and TR recruiting
[Music]
people